the creation of Seinfeld did Larry come
to you or did you go to I came I I
didn't go to him as much as I kind of
turned in the bar and catch a rising
star and said hey I had a meeting the
other day with the NBC they were
interested in me doing some kind of show
and would I be interested in in working
on it with him of course I really didn't
have anything going at the time and I
didn't have any money and I said sure
fine we left Patra rising star and we
walked into a Korean grocery store he
says uh what kind of show I go I don't
know I have no ideas I never have any
ideas I don't know how I'd do these I
have no ideas and we're wandering around
the deli and it's all sometimes it's
weird stuff you know there's like no
labels so we start making fun of the
products and he says to me this is what
the show should be
just two comedians talking because this
is what comedians do yeah they wander
around during the day with nothing to do
and make fun of everything that they say
and that was the Genesis